machine learning is a perfect technology
for this use case right I mean you you
think about how many data can be
produced by machines and by Cloud right
so that's massive amount of data and so
human we are very good at actually
watching videos like you know we can
recognize faces we can listen we can
actually recognize speech very well but
we cannot actually find out the
problematic machine among like millions
of machines no way you can do that we
are very bad at the time series analysis
um so
so that's why I think the AI technology
will play a very critical role
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders today I'm with Dr Helen goo PhD
who has made it her life's work to
create unsupervised machine learning to
detect anomalies in data in valuable
ways based on more than 15 years of
Helen's academic research and findings
she created Insight finder a tool that
can help predict and prevent I.T
incidents based on algorithms that can
determine an anomaly score and predict
the future impact on a company's
infrastructure the platform also
diagnoses the root cause of each system
issue and provides automated
self-healing capabilities to minimize
the impact of service outages in
addition to being the founder and CEO of
insightfinder she is also a computer
science professor at the University of
North Carolina and worked at IBM TJ
Watson Research Center where she worked
on the IBM stream processing system
called system s it later became IBM's
infosphere stream product
[Applause]
[Music]
Helen goo welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being with me
today how are you
good good thanks a lot for inviting me
here thank you very much for being with
me all the way from North Carolina
correct
yes North Carolina and New York oh
wonderful uh well um Helen you you were
quite a few hats uh computer science
professor at North Carolina State
University uh while also the founder and
CEO of insight finder obviously uh
computer science is a big part of your
life today focusing at least in the
inside finder and and with a few others
uh and further positions on on
unsupervised machine learning and I'm
looking forward to uncovering a little
bit about your journey and I'd love to
start all the way the third grade when
he started to learn how to program well
how
how does a third grader get to start
learning how to program and this is not
to today's third graders where we have
all these cool coding games for kids
this is a different time where it wasn't
as trivial so I'd love to hear your
story on that
yeah that's uh almost like 40 years ago
30 40 years ago right so it is a year
like you know I think we are still using
uh the first generation of apple and IBM
um so uh so it was actually a
interesting experience I was in the
elementary school and they were testing
how to teach kids with programming and
so our school was selected so I was
actually
um get curious about the programming and
so I joined the program and started
actually learning and I since I'm
falling in love with you know
programming and computer so that's how I
what was that what was that like for a
third grader to to be involved with this
experience of of learning and it also
sounds like this was it wasn't
necessarily a fully fledged out you know
curriculum that was you know you're
mentioning there you're sort of a part
of this experiment which obviously
succeeded given where you're at today
but what was that experience really like
for you yeah so they they only pick a
few uh you know kids to participants and
so I think it was actually most uh after
school class and so we are learning like
programming using you know drawing some
pictures it's very similar to scratch
but with some you know uh scripting
languages and so we um
uh we we you know learning basic you
know and we even have like a competition
and you can
um so the one program I remember very
clearly is that I made a kind of a
keyboard and you can play songs using
computer keyboard right simulating a
piano keyboard uh so that was actually
uh the fun experience I I remembered
yeah
so walk me through a little bit about
your trajectory from from learning how
to program yeah you were part of IBM
Watson research team and you were also
visiting scientists and within Google
Talk why walk us through a little bit
about your career trajectory leading to
this intersection of Academia and
Academia and and Entrepreneurship
yeah so um I started my PhD at the
University of Illinois and my PhD is
about these two systems I always
Fascinate about these river systems
because I believe you know one machine
won't do the all the work right so
that's all the starting point of you
know today's internet and you know
today's cloud computing right so it all
because distribut systems and then when
I started these sugar systems I started
to actually realize how hard to
programming a distributed program and so
it's a lot different more challenging to
make the program running smoothly on a
set of machines then you know compared
to just running on one machine so
reliability scalability and those has
been my passion so I want to actually
make the system reliable and so that's
my PhD work so my PhD work is about
using
um you know kind of algorithms not
necessarily machine learning and at that
time it's interesting I started to use
neural network when doing my first PhD
research it was using neural network to
predicting user preference and so where
they actually viewing the videos so we
were doing that the video mobile video
on demand so you can actually view the
videos uh at that time there's no
iPhones right so we have like you know
uh like a palm palette like the the
early days of compact computer and so um
you can actually view the videos and we
we enough to actually reduce the delay
so we predict what video user will watch
and we prefetch the video so I was using
neural network to predicting that and so
that's my first PhD research paper and
so later on so I um after I graduated
and I joined IBM TJ Watson as a
researcher and back then we started
actually a very interesting project is
building the first kind of commercial
grade distributed stream processing
system so real-time massive data
analysis that's way before Hadoop or
spark any of those you know lateral
system got invented so I was actually
responsible for maintaining again like
you know how to make a scalable and a
really reliable distributed real-time
data processing stream processing
platforms and so I work with a group of
researchers and they are basically using
this platform to do analysis like image
analysis video analysis text analysis so
they are machine learning expert but
they are analyzing basically not the
data produced by machine but you know
data produced by human right so um so I
started to actually get interested in
those machine learning algorithms and so
I'm saying okay you can use the you know
those hours into recognize patterns in
video uh can we use the algorithms to
recognize patterns in our machines so we
can actually predict okay whether this
machine is healthy or not and whether
this machine will actually you know go
down in in the in the near future so
that's how I get started using machine
learning to actually
detecting system problems predicting
system problems and so we were using
supervised machine learning and so uh we
get some initial very interesting
results we can predict you know like for
example disk failures pretty accurately
using those algorithms and so um then I
I love the IBM research because I want
to really pursue this uh this direction
so that's about like you know 15 years
ago and so so I I joined and said as a
faculty because you know I want to
actually really focus on this and I also
realize it is really hard to actually
apply supervised machine learning for
machine data because you need to
actually you know high quality label the
training data and so it's very hard to
actually label those machine data and
and you know a it's very massive second
is very frustrating so we start to
actually my students and I start to
actually focus on using and supervised
version learning and so that's how we
actually start our um you know research
ideas in basically as well as behavioral
learning and that's we uh we we start to
actually be able to predicting problems
without label training data and we
publish papers and so that's basically
when um Google actually
um you know a set of companies they
actually read the papers and they reach
out to us saying okay this is an
interesting paper can you can we use it
in commercial word so uh so I started to
collaborate with Google and so that's
how I end up being a visiting scientist
at Google testing our algorithms within
the Google environments and we
eventually show that using our
algorithms we can do much more um
accurate and scalable knowledge
detection at the Google scale so we
actually show that it has much higher
accuracy and and much better scalability
than other algorithms
um so so Google actually license the
technology and after that um I launched
the inside finder so we have been
actually developing many new
technologies and building the product as
well yeah wow and so take me back to the
original notion where you became
fascinated or passionate about you know
scalability reliability and detection
prevention from system failures what was
there
sort of it sort of was there an incident
that led you to to think this way was
there something that you that that led
you to to be so excited about this what
happened there
yeah so first of all myself is a
programmer right I read a lot of code
when I was doing PhD and also working at
IBM I suffer you know myself a lot from
debugging distributed systems and uh and
my my husband is also a soft engineer
and then you know he um you know he got
woke up by his manager during middle
night because the production issues in
his company right and so and so uh
myself and you know we just like feel we
use this technology all the time right
so um back then uh so I always feel like
you know um the technology most
important thing is connecting people uh
I think that's the most kind of powerful
thing uh technology did to the to the
human society and so um so one of the
examples I was actually using myself is
that when my son is Young he's a baby I
was using the next camera to to monitor
him right so I need to work and so I
cannot be at home so I use a camera to
Monitor and then and one day the camera
is it went down the service is gone and
I I don't know whether it's something
happen in my home or is because you know
the service is outaged right so so
that's basically just means and
sometimes if you use technology to do
like patient monitoring and that's
sometimes it's life it's
life-threatening if you have outages
right so that's that's why I I'm always
like passionate about this because you
know any minute you say
um you know any minute you reduce from
the downtime sometimes it means you save
lives
um so I so that's I think it's extremely
important
um rather than we we just wait here for
outage happens and we we you know uh we
have to suffer from unknown consequence
and so let's be proactive let's actually
Harvest all the data we can analyze and
the Machine learning is a perfect
technology for this use case right I
mean you you think about how many data
can be produced by machines and by Cloud
right so that's a massive amount of data
and so human we are very good at
actually watching videos like you know
we can recognize faces we can listen we
can actually recognize speech very well
but we cannot actually find out the
problematic machine among like millions
of machines no way you can do that we
are very bad at the time series analysis
um so
so that's why I think the AI technology
will play a very critical role yeah
so
no doubt about that and and then I'm I'm
personally so also Etc with the
technology and and and where we're
headed and the different things that it
allows us to do well what's a little bit
about the strategy of the Insight finder
how does the product work and you know
if you can share with me some some of
the you know key insights that you've
had into integrating sort of these
Solutions into the real world as
companies are you know obviously you're
you're tackling a problem that companies
have and how do you what is sort of the
narrative that you found the most
appealing to different organizations and
what what's been the right strategy here
yeah I think the you know we we are
trying to help our customers to change
from reactive monitoring to basically
proactive uh you know prevention right
so that's a fundamental Paradigm change
for a lot of customers and so nowadays
basically like I said the downtime the
outage means a lot of you know things
for for the company right Financial
penalty brand damages and you know
sometimes it's you know life-threatening
right so all those things act are
extremely critical and so if you know I
think the company want to find the
solution that can help them prevent from
them and so this is uh this is not new
problem it's a long lasting problem and
the problem becomes kind of more and
more serious because we are you know
moving into Cloud we are relying on
cloud and the and a lot of times in the
past right so you are using all days
like you are using IBM membrane you just
have one or two machines right so you
can hire people just sitting there and
watch babysit that but now you have I
don't know like you know tens of
millions of machines all over the world
and and how do you actually use human to
to watch all of that and to when
something bad happens and you you have
to actually manually diagnose and then
this is not going to last I think
um so so it is um you know it's a must
have uh kind of like you know capability
a lot of uh you know companies
and realize right they they have to have
these capabilities now uh we uh we're
seeing a lot of like tools are developed
in the space to help people to
collecting data monitoring data but we
see is that there's lacking basically a
good analysis tool that can help the
customer to figure out the insights out
of those massive data
and the human is not good at actually
analyzing machine data we are very good
at actually giving limiting information
we make decisions and so uh the problem
is that it's more like finding a needle
in a haystack right so you have so many
data and how do you narrow down and to
figure out okay how do I make a decision
now should I actually restart my machine
should I migrate to my application
should I add one more machine should I
actually configure upgrade my um my
database all those decisions right now
is made based on human experience and
it's empirical right and so a lot of
knowledges have gone when people
actually move their jobs so now
basically while using AI technology to
extracting all those insights out of the
massive data and make it persistent so
you can actually leverage that that you
know you can reuse that
yeah
really really interesting
um and do organizations understand this
as your you know talking about with them
what's been in their their set their
receptivity or the market education like
for you
yeah I think the our message resonates
very well with our customers and it's
it's not just like a you know uh big
customers and we start from like most of
Fortune 50 companies
um but then we also talk to Startup
companies right so one of our customers
is online education startup company and
they uh they serve over like you know
you know
um millions of students all over the
world and so um they don't have
resources to actually babysit and watch
their services all the time so the
reality inside finder to actually find
any like security bugs the security
breaches um
like a code box in their system
um they they can actually be you know uh
be assured that anything happen in their
infrastructure or application isabinder
will alert them and and they typically
can know the root cause and fix the
problem before their customers see it so
this message actually resonates well
with customers you know of all sizes so
the the question is that of course the
challenge is that you know um how to
actually get the data and how to into
the engine how to provide surface pop up
the insights to our customers and so
this is a very challenging problem and
not only it's a you know challenging
science science problem but also its
engineering problem it's both basically
also a usability problem because this is
a new product uh it's essentially you
are saying that you want to give a
crystal ball to our devops team to be
able to you know prevent the outages or
fix you know problems downtime quickly
so um this is a completely new uh thing
to our customers and the most of time we
need to actually guide them through this
journey yeah interesting how do you
create differentiation in the space
what is it what because maybe it's just
the buys that I have that you know I get
to participate in the space a little bit
so that there I know some some
interesting companies here how do you
how do you differentiate two customers
yourself from from different companies
who might be looking at tangential
spaces
absolutely so I think there's a lot of
uh like mentoring tools and the help
customer to actually provide a certain
um views to their systems but we see the
Gap is that you know everybody is trying
to build the ecosystems around
surrounding their tools and from the
custom perspective if they want to do
accurate will cost analysis and instant
prediction they need a data neutral tool
and this tool can actually plug into any
data you have right whether it's from
certain vendor or from the open source
software and so um so that's basically
the day one uh kind of our mission and
our positioning right so we are not
locked down to any vendors or tools
we're trying to be like you know um data
agnostic and you know application
agnostic so we can actually
allow the customer to plug in this
engine to any existing monitoring tools
they have all um kind of obserability
platform they have and what we do here
is basically extracting insights right
and so that's that's what we want to
laser focus on uh we are not monitoring
to a company we are not actually APM
company we are not observability
um company what we're trying to do is
that we we can turn all the existing
tools you have into more site yeah got
it
sounds really really cool and I love how
you are
I mean it sounds like over just the
years you've become this is a subject
that obviously you've become really
excited about and I still can't believe
you started and quoting so young I did
such a it's a really awesome journey and
and I love the intersection of Academia
and and Entrepreneurship and and
obviously leveraging really interesting
Technologies to to make it to make a
positive impact in in the Solar way that
you're doing with inside finder I think
that's that's pretty inspiring and so I
really want to thank you for taking this
time to spend your with me
um you know 20 minutes is way too short
to cover everything but hey it was still
really you're great hearing your story
and what you're doing with with inside
finder as well as Anna state so thank
you very very much Helen I really
appreciate your time best of luck with
and continued success with Insight
finder and I can't wait to share this
with others thank you
Michael yeah